if you had converted me to bisexuality
I'd probably would have had some actual
fun in the last 10 years instead of just
libertarian conferences hi I'm Tim
Kavanagh from reason TV we're here with
star child as a pro freedom activist and
Libertarian Party candidate for school
board in San Francisco right now thanks
for joining us no problem and this is a
special moment for me you are actually
the person who converted me to
libertarianism I called you up probably
more than 10 years ago now for an hour
in interview for suck calm a quick Q&A
and peppered you with all of the kind of
nonsense reductio questions that people
do you know when they're still in the
just hanging out at a roadside men's
room looking to get picked up part of
libertarianism how's anybody in a walk
on private sidewalks all this kind of
nonsense and you really had great
responses to everything and I appreciate
that but the funny thing is I didn't
know this until Tim told me to think two
minutes ago and I'm impressed and kind
of amazed to get at the time I thought
as I was saying you were libertarian
already and I thought you know this is
such a great interview because you were
going easy on me you're also an erotic
services provider to both genders and I
was going to say if you had converted me
to bisexuality I probably would have had
some actual fun in the last ten years
instead of just libertarian conferences
no it is true Woody Allen for the TT er
chances of a date on Saturday night
there you go so you're in San Francisco
what's not the first city anybody thinks
of when they think of libertarianism but
has a long pedigree with Murray Rothbard
having lived in a rent-controlled
apartment there and it's all kinds of
things I didn't know that's what's it
like being in the city by the well San
Francisco traditionally has been a
really wild place we go back to the gold
rush it was you know very an artistic
and these have parades of prostitutes
you know down Market Street every
Saturday the San Francisco Libertarian
Party by the way LPS s org has a
terrific actual video footage on Market
Street it's amazing I mean it really
shows how things worked without traffic
laws i mean people you know
you count the things that people were
doing which today would be legal
violations and you walk right in front
of the buses you know those cars but
there are still horses and things as
well just crisscrossing all different
angles and directions san Francisco has
this great history and in many ways it
still is culturally a very libertarian
place I got the feeling with your
question that you were focused mostly on
economics but we really shouldn't forget
the social side of it and then the
social aspect San Francisco is today I
think a very libertarian city by
American standards this has been a
recurring thing in libertarian history
of way you know it now's the time to
start siding with the left there's a the
liberal tarian movement now it never
takes off why did why is that why does
the left constantly you know provide
less welcoming ground than the right
this is a really good and interesting
question that goes into a whole bunch of
different areas I think I in Rand
perhaps the biggest single influence on
libertarians as far as individuals who
had an influence on the libertarian
movement she was brilliant and she did
the movement a lot of good in many ways
radicalizing people but I think she also
did the moving a lot of harm in many
ways libertarians became I think very
enamored of big business through her
influence very selfish in their
worldview I don't mean selfish entirely
in a bad respect but in terms of how our
libertarians were seen by others you
could contrast that sort of approach
libertarianism was like the Mary brewer
approach she's out there book healing
our world which I think does a terrific
job of describing libertarianism in
terms of social harmony and non
aggression and doing the right thing by
your neighbor and people getting along
and stuff like this and if libertarians
were more attuned to living that
manifesting that more I think we'd be
you know much more successful and find
much more commonality with people on the
left what do you think it and I say this
is a former San Franciscan current
Angelino and you know enemy of the state
but if I wanted to make the case for
good government for a city that works
fairly well I would point to San
Francisco and if I wanted to make the
case of you know a city fallen into
total chaos
I would point to LA is there anything is
that am I just not getting the right
bull unit you know what's good about San
Francisco in terms of how its government
works is it the populace is very
politically active now their instincts
are not always very good obviously
especially on the economic issues but
they are very involved and aware and
that does tend to keep government I
think pretty accountable to the people
in some respects compared to what goes
on in other places you're running for
City for school / scored right what's
the highest percentage you've gotten in
the lecture in San Francisco you know I
couldn't even honestly tell you I I mean
I don't obsess over stuff like that I
really see it as an outgrowth of my
activism something that we talked about
years ago and actually has now come to
pass unfortunately is open primaries
California's voters approved an open
primary law which effectively everybody
can participate in the primaries and the
Democrat can vote for the Republican in
the primary vice versa but then the top
two vote-getters run against each other
in the general election which means the
only election that actually gets me turn
out you have only two choices it limits
the ability of parties to control who
represents them and what that does
dilutes ideas we want parties to have
different viewpoints I mean here's an
interesting thing i've noticed that the
word ideology and people being
ideologues and so forth has really
gotten a bad rap lately it seems like
this is something that people always
talk about negatively they're being
ideological you know well i think you
know ideology is frequently a very good
thing it all depends what your ideas are
if you have good ideas that ideology is
great if you have bad ideas than it's
not great but it's certainly not
automatically bad where do you see
California go in the new libertarian
already given you know that's it's a
really good question i don't know i mean
i'm so frustrated with the many aspects
of the party what we really need is a
libertarian mass movement something from
the bottom up that you know really has
the potential to transform society do
the Libertarian Party is probably still
the single largest libertarian
organization which makes it
important potentially because every time
you know you see a revolution in the
world or a major social change it
usually involves large numbers of people
getting out into the streets Ukraine and
the orange revolution or the you know
the Philippines when they overthrew
Ferdinand Marcos sir you know anywhere
there's been a significant change like
that this is something you know the left
has been very good at getting people out
into the streets generally the
conservatives and libertarians not not
so much I mean you've seen this a little
bit more the tea parties and the Ron
Paul revolution 2008 I think was really
positive development because that you
know was sort of like the Inklings there
of a real libertarian mass movement but
unfortunately I'm being you know Ron
Paul being a Republican that it has
gotten sort of mixed in there the ideas
aren't as clearly defined there's they
need to be but the libertarian party's
not doing the things that it needs to do
I think like you know really reaching
out to youth it's a failure of
imagination I think two large degree
among libertarians libertarians still
kind of tend to accept a lot of the
basic ground rules of the game they
don't look to people who were thinking
outside the box with political parties
like the Black Panthers you know which
is not to say that the Black Panthers
were good in their ideology I mean they
weren't that libertarian but in terms of
their methodology we need a libertarian
Che Guevara we need people who can
capture the popular imagination because
they really you know take personal risks
and they they are their fiery and they
stand for their beliefs why do you think
it is the one who has captured the
public imagination is the most
unassuming uncharismatic you know Undine
amex a girl on Paul yeah you know I
think it's because Ron Paul has real
authenticity to him and that's very rare
in politics at his level and I think
that comes through people look at Ron
Paul and they can see okay he's not the
most polished speaker but he's really
speaking from the heart he really
doesn't seem like somebody and I don't
think he is somebody who is particularly
interested in power
a very humble guy and I think people
find that incredibly refreshing